alors avec moi un de ces grands
complices des 50 dernières années michel
tremblay bonsoir toi alors c'était
quelqu'un qui vous était très cher
c'était une amie proche et dans le
reportage vous disiez c'était votre muse
vous perdez une grande interprète de
voter oui absolument
quelqu'un pour qui j'ai écrit ça c'est
encore plus encore plus important j'ai
écrit au moins douze personnages de
terrain et deux personnages de cinéma
pour elle dans un sens au fil des années
j'ai l'impression que comme j'écrivais
pour elle comme elle mecs piret elle a
fait de moi un meilleur un meilleur
auteur de théâtre que je l'a été mais je
pense que c'est vrai pour tous les
auteurs qui écrivent pour des acteurs
qui qu'ils connaissent
mais je pense que ça aide aussi à
l'heure comment je dois la pertinence du
texte de savoir pour qui on est cuit ont
au fil des ans c'est la même chose avec
un débat sans avec avec le mettre en
scène au fil des ans on sait quoi leur
demander de plus mais eux aussi savent
quoi nous demander de plus le fait
d'entendre la voix de huit ans sa façon
très particulière de dire de modeler le
texte qu'elle disait sans doute en
améliorer ma façon on a dû mes pièces
meilleur dans un sens ce qui était si
particulier dans sa façon de moduler
mais ça s'explique pas c'est du solex
que c'était une façon de dire de chaque
chaque acte d'achat cactus
on envoie des actions les impôts ce
qu'ils sont ils ont tous une façon
personnelle bien sûr le style personnel
et vita est la bonne façon un petit peu
à la pid de parler avec sa belle voix de
mezzo soprano qui me touchait beaucoup
qui elle avait aussi une intelligence du
texte qui était absolument stupéfiante
un accepter que les textes elle
comprenait et comme grâce à sa grande
taille keita comme common des bassins
c'était pourquoi elle voulait savoir
pourquoi les répliques et l europe va
pas être tellement elle les incarner
donc j'en ferais ça ne s'est pas passé
des déclics ça ne savaient pas à quoi
servaient ces répliques la branche
c'était la même chose le permettait ce
que je pense et avec lui une vie
pourquoi elle dit soit tu as le moment
pourquoi 8 certain moment les têtes
comme ça la venue une intelligence très
très grande de ce que de ce que
signifiait ce qu'elle avait à jour on a
beaucoup dit aujourd'hui qu'elle qu'elle
était une actrice naturelle que qu'on
n'avait pas oui elle avait sept jours
parce que des fois des grands à qui j'ai
donné comme exemple kate kate blanchett
que gagne au score ya deux ans elle dans
le film de woody allen elle donnait une
performance absolument extraordinaire on
la voyait travail et la grande de la
grande qualité de ita c'est qu'on ne la
voyais pas travailler elle incarnait les
personnages tellement que elle devenait
cette veste est vraiment une incarnation
il devenait le personnage et on y
croyait et immédiatement on voyait pas
une actrice qui travaillent on voit un
personnage qui ont entre 5 qui disait
parce que ce qu'il avait à dire
et c'était je sais pas comment des
saumons n'avait pas à s'habituer aux
personnages l imposer immédiatement avec
un actuel stupéfiants et elle a
interprété le rôle de votre mère c'est
quand même
vous lui faisait confiance à ce point
c'était un peu un cadeau pour aimer ça
vous savez c'est du théâtre
comme je dis toujours les anecdotes sont
vraies mais les dialogues sont de moins
quand quand l'état avait dû la pièce
elle m'avait téléphoné à key west en 90
et elle m'avait dit et côté brouillon
j'ai joué de géologie plus tout ça mais
j'ai pas connu la neige peut pas lui
ressemble ifs et j'avais dit j'ai dit
même chose à guylaine tremblay kirpan
dans olé qui m'a envoyé un email
on me pose exactement la même question
en disant j'ai pas la peau semble apte à
main ou de représailles notamment et ce
que je devais les pompes devraient
toutes les deux c'est que ça nous en a
aucune espèce d'importance joue ce que
j'en ai fait joue le personnage de
théâtre que j'ai fait avec ma mère mais
le le début ce qui m'a inspiré la femme
qui m'a inspiré du sceau scène de plus
d'importance ce qui est important c'est
ce que j'ai fait d'elle et c'est ça
qu'il faut que toujours physiquement par
exemple olympia dukakis à rejouer la
pièce à san francisco c'est une toute
petite grosse comme ça pas mal et engels
tram c'est pas le physique ne peint pas
d'importance et ce qu'il appelle le
personnage dit et charité qui est un
papa et elle elle a su toucher les
québécois les québécois se
reconnaissaient en l accord justement je
pense c'est naturel à cause de la façon
pendant qu'elle avait deux jours qui
était très près de la réalité que
c'était du naturalisme dans le bon sens
de l'expression ll est leur semblait
tellement à des gens qu'on a connus
qu'on les maîtres suite des concours ou
qu'on les laisse entrer les yeux parce
que elle nous a bien toujours quelqu'un
qu'on a qu'on a connu quels souvenirs
vous allez
fidèle en amitié indéfectible et un
était une femme très fidèle en amour et
en amitié on était en amitié pendant
cinquante deux ans et je vais garder
d'elle évidemment les souvenirs de tat
fumio de cinéma ça c'est bien évident
mais je vais garder le souvenir d'une
femme d'une honnêteté absolument
incroyable merci beaucoup au châtelet